i'm sure you're all familiar with m m's
skittles snickers twix and milky way
bars those are some of the most famous
candy and chocolate brand in the world
and they're all owned by a company
called mars inc what you may not be
familiar with though is the people
behind mars
mars inc is actually one of the largest
privately owned companies in the world
and the company is still owned
completely by the founding family
today the family occupies six spots on
the billionaires list with all of them
being deca billionaires
this adds up to a total of
140.8 billion dollars which makes them
the richest private family in the world
so here's the story of the real life
willy wonkas
taking a look back it all started with
franklin clarence mars who was born on
september 24th 1883 in hancock minnesota
at a young age frank caught polio and in
an effort to make him feel better and
have a bit of fun his mother alva
decided to make some hand-dipped
chocolate candy
this was frank's first introduction to
chocolate making and he found the
process quite intriguing as he grew up
frank continued to learn how to make
various kinds of chocolate from his
mother including fudge and peanut brutal
and as soon as he turned 19 frank began
a small home business selling molasses
chips and other types of candies to
local stores
at the time chocolate was a rather new
invention people around the world had
been enjoying sweet treats since the
egyptians but the use of cocoa beans to
make chocolate wasn't a thing until the
late 1700s
originally chocolate was primarily
consumed as a drink by the rich and it
wasn't until 1847 that joseph fry
created the first chocolate boar
so it's quite surprising that frank's
mother was familiar enough with
chocolate that she was able to make her
own
anyway going back to frank he got
married quite young to a woman named
itoji kisak who was a schoolteacher they
got married in 1902 when frank was just
19 years old and they had a son named
forrest mars in 1904
unfortunately the two would divorce soon
after but what's funny is that frank
would go ahead and marry another woman
named ethel in 1910
one year later frank and itahini would
start the mars candy company together in
tacoma washington
the company specialized in wholesaling
fresh candy but they weren't the only
company in the area targeting this
market a company called brown and haley
came around just a few years later and
they would prove to be a lot more
successful
frank and ethel had a daughter named
patricia in 1914 and they tried to keep
up with the mars candy company as long
as they could
but eventually they threw in the towel
and moved to minneapolis minnesota in
1920.
in minneapolis the duo started a new
chocolate company called the marzo bar
that manufactured chocolate bars
in 1923 frank introduced a new chocolate
bar based on a sunforest idea called the
milky way bar
milky way became a customer favorite and
propelled the business into being an
up-and-coming chocolate company several
years later in 1929 frank would move to
chicago where he would come up with the
snickers bar
things were finally starting to pick up
and frank would start to enjoy himself
in the late 1920s frank started
construction on a massive estate called
the milky way farm
the estate consisted of a 25 000 square
feet clubhouse over 30 barns and it even
had a horse racing track
apparently frank employed 935 men to
construct the estate
but just as the estate was completed
frank would pass away at age 50 in 1934
due to heart problems
unfortunately it looks like enjoying his
walls just wasn't in the cards with the
frank dead the responsibility of running
the company naturally fell on his kids
but his son forest had already gone on
his own path
given that frank and his first wife etho
had divorced soon after forrest's birth
forest wasn't that close with his father
forrest and his mother had moved to
canada after the divorce and forrest
rarely saw his father
forest ended up attending the university
of california berkeley before
transferring to yale and graduating with
an industrial engineering degree in 1928
after graduation forest did join his
father's company but he didn't stick
around for too long at first forrest
oversaw the development of the snickers
and three musketeers bars but soon
enough forrest wanted to expand the
company internationally however frank
had no interest in expanding
internationally eventually the argument
would blow over and force ended up
moving to england alone in england
forest took on jobs at nestle and the
tobler company but he never let go of
his chocolate roots either in the
background forest was developing the
mars bar and mount teasers in 1934
forest bought a british company called
chapel bros which produced canned dog
food there was very little competition
in the market so it wasn't that hard for
forest dominate the dog food market but
after his father's death forest would
move back to the u.s
forest did oversee his father's company
but he wouldn't take over the company
for quite some time his stepmom ito
healey became the president of mars inc
and she was in charge of day-to-day
operations
in the meantime forest created his own
food business called food manufacturers
i think we can all agree that that's
literally the lamest name he could have
given the business
despite the lame name the company would
go on to be quite successful under food
manufacturers forest started two
sub-brands called uncle ben's rice and
pedigree the famous pet food brand
forrest kept coming up with new product
ideas from mars as well
in 1940 forrest came up with the idea
for m ms the idea was to create a
chocolate that didn't melt in your hands
but would melt in your mouth
given that this was during world war ii
though forest was worried that sugar and
chocolate would be rationed
so forest formed a partnership with the
president of hershey william murray
this way the two companies could share
resources if rationing wasn't forced
this is also how the name for eminem
came about the name was indicative of
the partnership between mars and the
murray ironically these companies are
massive rivals today
anyway a few years later in 1945 four's
stepmom passed away and this gave
forrest and his stepsister patricia the
full responsibility of running the
company in 1954 forrest introduced
peanut m ms and fun fact forest was
actually extremely allergic to peanuts
forest continued to run his father's
company and his own company separately
for another 10 years but finally in 1964
30 years after his father's death forest
merged the two companies
it's not clear what exactly happened to
patricia's stake in the business or if
she even had one patricia died just one
year later in 1965 and it doesn't look
like she had any kids so maybe forrest
inherited her steak after her death or
maybe he bought other steak while she
was still alive whatever the case though
forest was left with the entire business
given forrest's massive influence in the
company starting with the milky way bar
way back in 1923 i think this is only
fitting over the next decade forest
continued to run the company with a
tight fist forrest was notorious for
having an extreme temper and he highly
valued punctuality and performance
forced incentivize these traits by
offering a 10 bonus to all mars
employees
if the company was hitting performance
metrics and you were on time the entire
week you got a 10 bonus that week but if
you were late even once you
automatically lost a bonus regardless of
whether you're a janitor or an executive
forrest officially retired in 1973 and
age 69 but he had quite a bit of trouble
actually letting go
he left the company with his three
children forest junior john and
jacqueline
apparently he would call his kids all
the time to nitpick at things that they
weren't doing quite right but eventually
for forest senior lightened up on his
kids after he founded a new chocolate
company to run in 1981 forrest senior
moved to henderson nevada and founded
ethel am chocolates he ran the company
for seven years but in 1988 he would
sell the company to mars inc and truly
retire
ford's senior ended up passing away in
1998 at age 95 after living a stunning
life as for more zinc the company only
grew even larger under the leadership of
forest kids
after forest senior left the company the
kids move their headquarters to mclean
virginia the company is super famous for
being secretive so we don't know too
much about their internal operations or
business decisions but one avenue of
growth that we are aware of is their
public acquisitions and the kids haven't
been shy when it comes to acquisitions
they bought the chewing gum company
wrigley jr in 2008 for 23 billion
dollars
similarly they bought three pet food
brands from png for 2.9 billion dollars
in 2014. they also expanded into new
areas through acquisitions
for example in 2003 mars acquired
aquarium pharmaceuticals which allowed
the company to enter the aquarium and
bond markets
similarly they bought banfield pet
hospital in 2007.
since then morris has doubled down on
the veterinary market mars went ahead
and bought blueprint veterinary partners
in 2015 vca inc in 2017 and the lineage
group in 2018. all of these acquisitions
have actually made mars the largest pet
nutrition and veterinary care provider
in the world today the kids aren't
really kids anymore as they're in their
80s and forest junior actually passed
away in 2016. his take in the company
was evenly split between his four
children who all work at mars as well
as for john mars he has three kids but
we don't know what exactly they do and
if they're even involved with the
company john himself has chosen to live
an extremely private and peaceful life
in wyoming in fact he's kept his life so
private that when forbes was making
their billionaires list from 2010 to
2014 they couldn't find a picture of him
which made him the richest person on the
list without a picture
and finally we have jacqueline who is
likely the most public of the three
we don't know too much about her three
children either but in 2013 jacqueline
was involved in an infamous car accident
near her house
jacqueline claims that she passed out
while driving but she tested negative
for drugs alcohol and medication
so it's not clear what exactly caused a
blackout
but unfortunately the accident resulted
in a person dying and a pregnant woman
miscarrying jacqueline pleaded guilty
and profusely apologized for the
incident
fortunately for jacqueline she was
eventually able to walk away from the
situation with a misdemeanor charge for
reckless driving and that's the story of
the 141 billion chocolate family did you
guys know about the mars family comment
that down below also drop a like if you
love snickers
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm ari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
you